How do we feel about our boyfriends
fiancé’s/husbands having a girl best friend?
my fiance absolutely has a girl best friend
They do everything together
they go out on weekends
they hang out during the weekday
they watch Netflix
hang out on the couch
They cuddle play board games
They have a drink, eat their favorite snacks together
They talk all the time
texting, FaceTime even Snapchat
You name it they're doing all of it
They rarely go a day without ever speaking
In fact I don't even think they've ever gone a day without speaking
They even go on vacation together
it's great because he has someone that he never gets tired of
Always wants to be with
they always wanna hang out
never gets bored to hang out with her
It’s great because
that girl is me
she is me I am her
I'm his only girl best friend
his only best friend